just so we're clear my principal still  hold I'm not committing any acts of  violence dude we're about to go into  battle watch me put that on everybody  else was doing it you know I'm not I'm  not really that comfy with the whole  spearing part I'm hoping Spears was  designed for soldiers likes an alert  focus productive but sadly this had a  little bullet Factory is my endgame I'm  getting a soda here okay what's your  plan huh hi fellas  simply to show some collaboration mr.  Ganz which one of you wants a taste wait  you two are gonna take them on that's  great we're all gonna die  I like my steak well-done and that's how  I like my coworkers  you